where is 30 on the number line so on the  number line right over here we see we'll  just go from zero the first last year  isn't one it's three so every slash here  is going to go up by three so let's say  figure out where 30 is so this is  already marked as three now this is  going to be three more is 6 9 12 15 18  21 24 27 30 another way you could have  thought about it is if each of these  marks are three to get to 30 we have to  go to ten of these marks so you go 1 2 3  4 5 6 7 8 9 10 let's do a few more where  is 24 on the number line  well once again each of these marks is  again 3 so it's going to be 3 6 9 12 15  18 21 and 24 let's do one more so now  each mark is 4 so we're going to go 4 8  12 16 20 another way you could think  about it is if we're going up by 4 you  have to go up 5 times to get up to 20 so  this is 1 2 3 4 5  either way this should be the right  answer